[Musik]
ich fliege in eineinhalb stunden nach
wien
zudem habe ich noch nichts gegessen
sondern die zähne geputzt hat und ich
mein video aufgenommen so leute ich
nehme jetzt gerade im video auf und max
putz den hintergrund für die masse was
trägt was er ist dann braucht man sicher
zum flughafen
[Musik]
b
was ist das eigentlich für kranke kinder
davon halte ich es gerne an druck machen
so wie sie es gern noch ein probieren
einkaufen durch die sicherheitskontrolle
luca was nimmst du damit max max guten
start kann niemand aus
dass man antworten privatsphäre wird
ganz groß geschrieben bei marx mit 13
treffern im st
kochen
fünf liegen wie in china
aber wahr machen ihr kommt aus dem
flieger und lauft erstmal noch fünf
kilometer
wie es halt der schnellste von uns ist
genauso wie beim sex auf fragt unser
hotel ist da ist der flughafen gewesen
noch und dort ist unser hotel direkt am
flughafen
luca was ist dein erlebnis exposition
ist angekommen im hotelzimmer wir schon
mal die aussicht an
[Musik]
da freut man sich dass man ich bin jetzt
hier bald ja noch nicht mal warum guckst
du so dumm
das ist jetzt nicht war überall mobil
max wie ist es somit luca
zusammenzuarbeiten so das ist ein kanal
name zum wievielten mal hat ist heute
geflogen
zum vierten mal dabei ums leben
sozusagen das vielflieger warum in der
letzten reihe wenn besuch da muss auf
jeden fall kaum platz um sich auszuleben
welt ihr dumm es konkreter
es ist so schön mit dir wir sind die
kaum halt von bring die pudding mit drin
weiterhelfen was ein 14 heute abend als
amt ist wenn sie mal der hund der nacht
und wenn sich das essen von machen
kennst du das neue management von qsc
aber der ist ihnen damit adidas zusammen
wisst ihr wo wir definitiv nicht viel
geld ausgeben
[Musik]
ist das lecker das hirn roman du mit
deinem blüten auf den grünen blüten
spricht ein bisschen abstand ist der
wald das ist ja mal gar ein schon getan
habe die chips die chips sind einfach
schon leer
die sag uns doch mal wer dort oben auf
der auf dem bild erkennen das ist
handwerk wurden diese allem ein name ist
super ich bin 21 jahre alt ist
ich hoffe der laden hat kein hallo
robert hat ihr einmal die augenbraue zu
was hältst du von der kosten
wie bewertest du den massen auf der
skala von zwei bis fünf machen
das war es jetzt hier vom ersten block
aus berlin durchgefallen hat das gerne
mal leider sonst sehen wir uns in porto
wieder
[Musik]